Ja, ich wollt' jetzt grad a Kommentar posten zum ...
... ja ... zum Weltgeschehen überhaupt.
Zur Klimakrise, was ois los is ...
... mit dem ganzen Corona-Zeig und ...
Aber jetzt hab i a Meldung in der Zeitung gelesen ...
und die hat mi jetz so erschüttert, dass ...
Ich hab jetzt wirklich gleich a paar Notfalltropfen nehmen müssen.
Da hat nämlich ein Mann ...
Ein Mann, der hat ... der hat sei Leberkässemmel kauft.
Und wollt n mittelscharfen Senf. Und sie hat dann a ...
Sie hat dann a süssen Senf drauf tue, und er hat gesagt, er vertragt des net und ...
Dann hat er die Polizei g'holt, ...
... sie net ihm a frische Semmel geb'n wollt.
I woiss net! Wo leben wir?
Was kommt als nächstes?
Dass so einer Pommes frites bestellt mit Ketchup ...
... und kriegt dann Mayonnaise.
Des is koa Welt, in der i leben mag.